Good morning, and welcome to the second day
of Next.
And today I’m excited to announce that we
are adding three more regions to the set.
I hope you like live demos, because this is
the first of four live GCP demos you’re
going to see in the keynote today.
And I couldn’t be more excited to have Spanner
be the first one.
Starting today, GCP VMs will come with up
to 64 Cores and 416 GB of memory.
First, I’d like to congratulate Google on
being the absolute first to have cloud services
on our next generation Xeon processors, Skylake.
Great, thank you.
For a one- or three-year commitment, you receive
a discount for up to 57 percent, billed monthly
with no upfront payment.
You can add a GPU to any of VM configuration
and start it up in under a minute, much faster
than our competitors.
Within a matter of minutes, we are able to
mix the CPU’s GPUs high ratio, memory close
to the processor, the way we need for particular
algorithms to work in a very good way.
So, this is a big advantage that we get out
of Google, but I would say that another advantage,
as Urs Hölzle said himself, I think Google
should be very proud of having someone like
this...Alright, let that be stricken from
the record, that was not in the script.
We put a security chip on all our new machines
to serve as the basis of trust for that machine’s
identity.
This is a custom chip, designed by Google.
We know exactly what it does, and it helps
us protect serves against tampering even at
the BIOS level.
The chip, in fact, is so small that I’m
actually wearing one on my earring here.
We’re announcing several new security features
that we’re adding to GCP and G Suite.
Data loss prevention...DLP makes it easy.
When he ends the chat we will use data loss
to identify and redact sensitive information.
This isn’t just dumb OCR, you’ll notice
it didn’t block out the expiration date
or the name, because we told the API that
the only information we wanted to eliminate
is credit card numbers.
Next, Cloud’s key management service is
now generally available, and we also added
tools that let you safely access that secure
content.
The first one is Identity Aware Proxy security
And last but not least Security Key Enforcement
is now available.
It’s really important to us that for developers
and Windows developers, that we meet them
exactly where they are.
We want to be a great windows platform, perhaps
the best Windows platform.
Today, we’re announcing the general availability
of SQL Server Enterprise and that actually
includes support for a higher availability
as well as clustering.
Also, a beta of .NET and that will be available
for both App Engine and Container Engine.
And to help people on this journey, we’re
announcing a new Windows partner program so
now Linux or Windows, MySQL, Oracle or SQL
Server, and as of today, also a beta of Managed
PostgreSQL.
We recently added, right from the cloud console,
the ability to migrate a virtual machine to
GCP.
And this is more than transcoding an offline
image.
It is actually the live migration of a running
server to GCP.
So what is the best test for moving to the
cloud with minimal friction?
Probably to be able to do that with zero downtime,
so welcome Jack Constantine from LUSH to tell
us about their journey.
The actual migration was from December the
1st until December the 22nd, so it's not just
a little bit business critical, we’re talking
peak trade time.
It was a huge deal.
We moved 17 websites, from all over the world
with customer data, order data, product data.
You obviously want that all up and stable.
You know, back in 2008 Google App Engine was
really it was pioneering serverless, and it
was ahead of its time.
So now out of the box, we support seven popular
languages - Java, Ruby, Go, PHP, Python, C#
and Node.js - or you can now for the first
time, bring your own run time, bring your
own framer, to App Engine Flexible Environments.
As long as it runs in a Docker container,
it runs on App Engine.
Serverless is a really important concept and
today we’re announcing the beta of our newest
serverless offering, Cloud Functions.
We’ve also integrated the Cloud Functions
that we just talked about with Firebase.
That allows Firebase developers to extend
their backend logic in crazy ways and today
we are making firebase even more powerful.
Now you can access any GCS bucket, anywhere
in the world, right from Firebase.
We integrated cloud storage into the Firebase
STKs.
Great companies use data to react faster to
the market, build novel new products and even
change culturally how they work.
Announcing the Google BigQuery Data Transfer
Service.
What that does is it automates the transfer
of data from SaaS applications in the BigQuery,
but it does it on a scheduled, managed basis.
That’s why today we are introducing Cloud
Dataprep.
Dataprep is this intelligent service that
allows you to visually explore and clean your
data so that is can be integrated into a BigQuery
environment.
As Apigee, we know a thing or two about APIs.
We process billions of API codes in our cloud.
You process billions of API codes using our
technology, in your cloud.
Everybody is choosing the cloud.